all right guys here's the big picture
you're shopping for a laptop what are
you doing what do you want what do you
want in your laptop where there's a
whole lot of things that come into play
when you're shopping for a new laptop pc
now i happen to have a brand new 17-inch
model of this dv the hp pavilion dv17
i'll be glad to go over it for you but
i'm just going to go through a list and
you can see this link in the description
of exactly how to pick what laptop you
want to buy
and i hope these tips are helpful for
you so i'll go down the different parts
of a laptop and see exactly what which
ones you might be interested in
so i'm going to start with the processor
the processor is one of the key features
of a laptop it determines how fast
you're able to process information as
far as opening and closing programs and
downloading and installing and basically
the ability to process things now
some notebooks use amd's and some
notebooks use intel i happen to have an
intel core 2 duo running at 2.83
gigahertz it's a decent it's a decent
machine and
i'm pretty sure this is a good processor
for me to recommend to you guys now for
i have to start by saying this is a
17-inch
high-end notebook pc basically so um
that's the first the second part is the
brand of the processor which right now i
have to recommend the intel core 2 duo
of course you can also go with an amd
turion you can go with the turion 64
64-bit processor
and i can go a lot into processor
features in a later video if you so
desire
so the next part i'm going to go into
about your system is your ram
right off the bat i'm going to tell you
i well i have a
there's a lot of stuff that goes into
your ram but right now i have an 8
gigabyte i have 8 gigabytes of ddr3 ram
um that i actually had to install into
this laptop manually because at the time
that i customized it there was no option
for eight gigs of ram
so
windows vista generally is going to
require i'm going to say 2 gigabytes of
ram you're not going to want to go with
anything less than 2 gigabytes of ram
even if your window running in windows
basic mode with absolutely no themes
turned on you're going to want at least
2 gigs of ram for windows vista
and
there's also the ddr2 ram versus ddr3
ram and i highly recommend going with
ddr3 if you can afford it um i just got
i happened to pick up some ddr3 ram it
was extremely inexpensive and i'll give
you the newegg.com link eventually if i
can find it again but it's probably
selling out so
that uh that determines a lot of the
speed of your computer the more ram you
have generally the more applications you
can have running at once without having
a little bit of lag when the animations
come in
by the way windows 0 i found out uses
about 200 megabytes of ram so if you
turn arrow and transparency and
everything off you'll save about 0.2
gigs of ram
so there's also the 32-bit versus 64-bit
issue which again is going to be the
topic for a separate video
uh the 32-bit operating system which
i've had the privilege to have
um i had four gigabytes of ram at the
time and i only had
about 3.2 gigahertz gigabytes recognized
by that 32-bit operating system now of
course i have 8 gigs of ram so i needed
obviously to upgrade to 64-bit windows
vista which can handle up to a hundred
and something gigabytes of ram i'll get
back to you on that
so that is a really nice feature and i
recommend getting at least two gigs of
ram again if you're using windows vista
so and that'll also extend your battery
life of course because the more ram you
have the less time you have to access
the hard drive which uses a lot of
battery
next is i'm going to say your hard drive
i'm just going off the bat here so just
pardon me the hard drive is there's two
major components to the hard drive and
that is the size and the speed
the more hard drive space you can afford
the more i recommend if you can go with
the dual hard drive i also recommend
that
however if you do have external storage
i don't recommend going for size i'm
going to say go down the speed route um
when i was shopping for my laptop i
noticed three different sizes of
processors that you could actually or um
hard drives pardon me that you could
actually go with you could go with a
4200 a 4200 rpm hard drive which is a
very low end
not really it's like a 13 inch ultra
portable that you just have you happen
to have a cd drive and listen in music
then you go with the mainstream 5400 rpm
hard drive
and this laptop i got i decided i have a
500 gig external hard drive here made by
western digital so i didn't need size so
i just went with speed when i increased
the price
and
i went with a 250 gigabyte 7200 rpm hard
drive which is perfect for me and trust
me the performance increase was worth it
i was working with a 4200 rpm hard drive
and i did not like
that kind of experience so that is the
hard drive part of it
the next part is graphics your graphics
card is probably
one of the top most important parts of
your laptop there's graphics memory
based on how much is actually needed
to
dedicated to processing your video the
built-in integrated graphics by intel or
whatever they're they're going to be
terrible
i'll tell you that off the bat they're
going to be bad
but if you do if you do go with an
external graphics card obviously it uses
a tiny bit more battery but gamers and
highest desktop replacement notebooks
are going to have you're going to want a
512 my graphics card and if i could pull
it up here i'd show you but we have
i have about i have a 512 meg graphics
card it's an nvidia geforce 90
700 m i believe but i'll have to double
check on that so that's
that's basically that's the basic load
on on graphics memory again a separate
video if you so request
the next is your screen mine laptops are
continuing continually having larger and
larger screens mine is a 17-inch desktop
replacement you can go with a mainstream
notebook with about a 15.4 inch or a
14.1 inch and the more portable ones
have even smaller screens such as a
13-inch or when you get down to the
netbooks like a 9-inch or anything
but i've also seen 18-inch laptops and
yes a 21-inch laptop so don't be
surprised there are huge laptops out
there and obviously more the bigger your
screen and the brighter it is the more
it'll suck battery but hey that's the
price you pay
um
what i would recommend
is if you really like to game or watch a
lot of videos then you would go with a
higher definition screen obviously but
there's really not much to talk about i
have a 1680x1050 screen on the 17 inch
laptop you could also go with 1440x900
or i know someone who has a 16 inch
laptop whose resolution was about 1300
by 768.
anyway the last part i want to go over
is your battery
um when you again using a different
processor will determine how much
battery life you're going to get out of
your laptop and intel core 2 duo is
going to last longer than the amd turion
taking steps that i've shown you in
other wireless or other videos i've
shown you about battery such as turning
off wireless or uh using less graphics
or background tasks can cut down on how
much battery you actually use
so that's basically that's basically my
laptop tips tutorial for you guys
subscribe if you like this video
it was a pleasure teaching you guys
exactly how i got my laptop and again
customizing your laptop is going to be
the best thing you want to do
go online and look for different deals
that you can get such as like online
retailers like newegg.com which i'll
show you guys later psystar.com a lot of
videos um are to come on these topics so
again thanks for watching and i hope you
like this video tutorial and
any other video requests definitely pm
me and i will get to it thanks guys
peace